you guys kept talking about bringing it  back and doing other stuff but like you  would hear about it like hey they're  talking about doing this and then  nothing would come of it was that on  your side or the networks both buzz  what's the closest you came we were  going to do something with wine it was  all very awkward because Kelly was  signed to e at the time oh yeah and this  guy who ran E at the time he and I had  an argument and he actually could you've  now got great dinner conversation  because you could show this conversation  you can say tell everyone you called me  a [ __ ] so are you happy now over and  over again honestly I swear to I can't  remember his name but he got fired and  I'm like not because he caught me a cut  I didn't tell anyone but um anyway when  he got fired I did the happy dance you  didn't you don't seem like you were  broken by that were you really wounded  when he said that to you